[Musik]
das zu der R Reportage wenn Eltern sich
trennen wie weiter mit der Familie mit
der serina Herzberg sie ist Leiterin von
der fachstell Elternschaft und Unterhalt
und ich darf jetzt mit ihrw V
interessante Frage und Kommentar
besprechen bevor wir richtig sch brüchla
fachstellter Schaft ungerhut was heißt
es konkret trennige ja W such sch die
fachstell landet hier sind Elter von der
Stadt zü wo Unterstützig such wenn sie
sich frü oder wenn sie sich schon länger
TR und der Ver familiensituationatt wenn
sie ne betreug W Regel oder w Finanz
klären und wenn Sie alleine oder findet
sie würde gerne unterstützt werden dann
met sie sich
perfekt für die
Kommentar
Kommentar dererie
z. bis wo schribt als Kind von
getrennten Eltern finde ich die
Vorgehensweise vor den Kindern so über
den anderen Elternteil zu sprechen ist
fatal furchtbar was das mit den Kindern
macht ja wie ist es wter schlecht
Ving R also ich möchte einach V schick
he Welt und auch in der bestte Familie
vor dass man mal strittet dass es mal
lut wird dass manft über andere ältere
Teil aber schwierig ist es für für Kind
wenn sie gehören dass ein älter Teil
standändig schlecht gemacht wird mit DF
nicht vergessen Kind treit bei die
ältere Teil in sich Vater und Mutter und
wenn ein ter Teil ständig schlecht
gemacht wird fragt sich das Kind
unbewusst ja bin ich auch so W ich auch
mal so und das kann dazu führre im
schlimmst Fall dass da Kind ein Teil von
sich abspaltet und das ist nicht gesund
und das Mus wirklich aufpassen als Elter
mus sich im wieder bewusst sie Kind ich
nicht einfach ich von mir sondern kindib
bei die ältere Teil sich und die W auch
se und gewürdiget werde
Jessica schriebt das Problem sehe ich
vor allem darin dass Paare zu lange
zusammen bleiben solangee bis sie sich
richtig hasse es war viel sinnvoll dem
Hinblick auf King W Sie sich vorher
Schlussstrich würde Zeh und L wie sie
aus ter Team funktionieren ich GLB für
viel paar was Training überlegen so die
SAG ne
nicht B gr
bis lohnt sich das US ja es lohnt sich
wenn g Respekt und achtig vin da ist
denke solange das da ist muss man
wirklich miteinand L wmen bieben W nicht
bieben es ist auch Möglichkeit dass man
sich de Unterstützig holt für viele
Elter ist es nicht so einfachsicht dran
es gibt finanzielle Hindernis das heiß
viel Elter sind auch mehr oder weniger
zwungen aus und in de Situation denke
ich ist es wichtig D man miteinander als
Familie zamitzen wie W wie W das Thema
da so im rum STT wie W wir das miteinand
lös und
Kind nach Möglichkeit mit i beziehen und
dann kann ich das schon
Lohne besser sie we die Konflikt die
ganze Zeit derheim stattfinden tren oder
kan besser reden oder es geht einfach im
ein Bereich entlastig W man nicht mit
dem konfrontiert ist es geht natürlich
dann auf andere s eine belastig
Situation verändert sich und sie wird
anders und in dem anders K sich finden
und miteinand ja was ist denn für dich
anders was ist für mich anders was ist
vor allem füres Kind anders wie wir
machen dass das anders fürs Kind wenig
am wenigst belastend ist der nch
Kommentar zielt auf die verwandte
kurzuser schribt ein zentraler Aspekt
für anhaltende Streitigkeiten sind die
Verwandten und Bekannten der Eltern
Teile welche statt helfen aufeinander
zuzugehen für
polarisier SP verwand die größer
familiiereis also grö famekreis Freunde
und Verwandte Spiel sehr große Rolle dem
ganz sehr wichtige Rolle sieön gerade
für Kind Kön sie so eine Konstante in
dem ganz Sturm da s das Großelter gö
Gotte und es ist wichtig dass in dem
ganze knusch V bezieh wo ja dann sich
halbiert auf dass es menso da bewusst
wertschätzen die Rolle gegenüber
beidenter
lurm stürmischen Meer was wie Sicherheit
schöne Vision wie man Familie unstütz ja
genau Michael h
5665 schriebt tolle Reportage mer der
stell ich kann mich mit dieser
Geschichte identifizieren es wäre auch
interessant zu beleuchten wie Kinder
sich fühlen wenn ein Elternteil nach der
Trenung neue bezieh geht was macht das
mitming das sehr unterschiedlich Kind
wie einmal meh es ist Hal sehr
unterschiedlich auch innerhalb der gich
Familie hat das sehr unterschiedlich
erlebt werden von der Kind das E sich
dann zum mit dem Verlassen älter Teil
solidarisiert und dann der ne Partner
schüß das ist so der Klassiker aber kann
umgekehrt sie das dann sehr geborfühlt
neue System und dann
eigentlich andere tere Teil F stört das
ist ganz
verschieden Freunde von mir jetzt und
wenn jetzt da eine neue Bezi SP würd den
empf es nicht sofort kommunizieren
undings zit und der
später mit dem konfrontieren oder gerade
vfang transparent es kom wie Situation
ist wenn jetzt die tränik noch sehr
frisch ist und alles ist noch sehr
aufgewt dann ist es aber je wieder nach
Konstellation vielleicht ist ja sch lang
die bezieh bekannt oder ins geheim dann
ist vielleicht gut wenn man mit
grundsätzlich s sch off Kommunikation
will das ein wichtig findet nicht das Z
Schluss Kind weiß Geheimnis von Mami
oder von Papi und kom dann in blöde
Situation nicht verplpper oder so
interessante Frage schribt ne
3 die letzte gezeigte Variante vom Film
finde ich die heikelste das ist die
familiewge Ramon undet immer gich
einfach wie
liebesbezi die beendet die Eltern sind
nicht mehr zusammen aber tun so wie als
wäre nichts gewesen wenn es zur Trennung
kommt dann sollte es meiner Meinung nach
zu einer physischen Trennung kommen Teil
die Kritik J die Geschichte ist eige und
es gibt unterschiedliche Zite für für
der train gibt unterschiedliche zit und
ich finde es ist schwierig V beurteil
wie
trainblaufen Bilder im Kopf wie das G
erfah e Geschichte
bewertigge das heißt aber nicht nur ist
d es nicht funktionieren sie sehr
transparent gegenüber sind sieter wer
werd sie mehr Frage wir müssen erklären
und ichuck die machen das von dem
her
nicht Problem ich danke es ist ganz
wichtig dass J die Familie auch gesse
Flexibilität bewahrt WN man sich mal auf
irgend Modell D man nicht se ja das ist
jetzt so für die nächste 10 15 Jahr ger
jetzt noch losgöst V V der Kommentar W
wie find passen Mod nach tren für der
Familie es kom auf Bedürfnis von der
Familie duf aufs Alter von der Kind auf
der wbsituation von der ter auf die
finanzielle Möglichkeit wo um sind auf
der wohnmarkt
gibt's neue Partner wie G man mit dem um
wie ist distanzverhältnis ist das nur
ganz schwierig also muss man jetzt mal
dieand schaffen oder halt wir das der
das sind so die
Hauptsachen Modell kann man sich
vorstellen wierhin gemeinsamen Haushalt
führen und Film git die verschiedene
Mod oder familienwege ja wie verbreitet
sie die verchedene Mod zah ja der Schwiz
ist nach vor so
haupbetrsresidenzm am verbreit das das
ist so der Klassiker wo man früh g
gerichtsübliches Besuchsrecht hat das
fri Kind sind un Woche meint Elterteil
und alternierend wen be einim andere
ältere Teil das ist nach vor verbreit
das ist aber sichum aufweiche
alternieren die ob wo wo nachfragt wird
will auch gesellschaftlich Wandel das
gerade P die alltagsbetreu involviert
werden und wen den Part alltagsbetreu
nicht nur so der Wochenend Spaß
Bezugsperson sie V allem die städtische
Region wird das zunehm nachfragt und
aucht der ländliche Region eher weniger
aber es ist am und es ist die Granze
sind aufweichen oder dass man geht nicht
nur einfach 5050 und jedes zweite Wochen
son es geht ja zwisour V fr bis oder das
tut sich
B viele machen das am Anfang von TR als
übergangslösig ist Mod sehr
anspruchsvoll
ist
geminsushfüg ist standz
sehr andere Partner die Spiel gbt
einfach große es ist machbar und es ist
sicher für
Kind
sie kann aber dazu führen dass Kind
natürlich die sind dann die sind che die
sind immer und
Elter die
Frage was gar
Verst Konflikt also früh g Alter die
nicht W Elter so verstritt sind
und hat bundesgicht
auch ja
F WN sie das nicht W das irgendwi auch
nicht und dass man jetzt seid ja je
nachdem ist es möglich es braucht
einfach genau die fixe klare Absprache
das ist ganz wichtig ich glaube nicht
vergessen ich mE 90% von der Elter die
Kri auf drei also mir Hand die
schwierige Fall wo sehr zstrittte sind
wo alle Behörde alle beratstelle sehr
beschäftigt alle kicht aber wir haben da
ganz viel Leute das nach Übergangsphase
und noch
Ringe irgendwie gut auf dre krieget m
mit sehr fixen Absprache man mit
Lockerheit man Kunst Kollegialität
freschaft zwischen der ter aber es geht
wirklich est hoff und ich glaub muss
auchade immer wieder die zu sich und sag
hey and daschafft und wir größer und es
git wieder andere und irgendwann m oder
Papi soig und komt wieder gut Abschluss
machen
Kommentar vielen lieben Dank an alle
Eltern die so bereitwillig Einblick
gegeben haben in ein Thema bei dem es
sowieso jeder besser weiß ich habe die
verschiedenen Modelle vorher nicht
gekannt und fand es mega spannend
zuzuhören ich glaube dieser Beitrag wird
sehr vielen eine Hilfe sein ich hoffe es
sehr fest und mir dank GT auch der
Ältere da inblck vom le und ich das ist
St für
Familie trainingsituation s mer für mal
fr
Herzberg